في بوركينا فيها صوت طالبه متظاهرون
مؤيدون للرئيس المجلس العسكري ابراهيم
تشاوري طالبوا برحيل القوات الفرنسيه عن
بلادهم ردد المتظاهرون وسط العاصمه وجدوه
شعارات تطالب بالتحالف مع روسيا وتمدد
بالرئيس الفرنسيه
بوركينا فاسو صاحب القوات الفرنسيه من
البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منه وجدوه بين مراسل الجزيره بابا ولد
حرمه بابا مظاهرات تطالب رحيل القوات
الفرنسيه بالتحالف مع روسيا الى اي مدى
تعكس المزاج العام في الشارع في بوركينا
فاس
اليوم صباحا واستمر
الماضيه حتى قبل تقريبا هذه المباراه
مماثله كانت شهدتها بوركينا فاسو وعدد من
دول غربيه افريقيا
اه طبعا هناك ايضا هذا لنقل انه هذا
الموقف
الحدثنا مع بعضها الفنانين مع بعض قاده
الاحزاب السياسيه لا يبدون لا
يقفون نفسها الموقفين من باريس يقولون ان
الوضع متشابك في هذه البلدان وان الازمه
عميقه وابعاد كبيره وبالتالي فان هذا
الاستعجال نحو استبدال روسيا بفرنسا قبل
لا يحمل الجبريه مشاكل هذه الدول اما
بالنسبه للشباب المنظمات المدنيه التي
توالي هؤلاء قادتها العسكريين فانه الوقت
اللي تبدل هذه الدول من استراتيجتها خاصه
ان روسيا عززت حضورها في دوله لكن هذا
الحضور الروسيه حميده معه مقود يتعلق
بوجودي همم
لتجاوزات بعض التقاريدي همم
من وجدوهم مراسل الجزيره بابا والحرمه
شكرا جزيلا لك